so a few months ago I was location
scouting for Riley rewind at a bunch of
different high schools when this
happened
great sense of style yeah so like any
self-respecting American of course I
kidding
but it's funny because these girls
thought but I was in high school in that
moment I remembered exactly how shitty
everything about high school was
honey daddy every school you're gonna be
late
no and zigs and morning what's wrong
with the people great our public school
system
oh but nothing compares to the bitchy
popular girls am i right what are you
looking at loser and I mean it's sad you
know kids are so fucking mean I mean my
sister was bullied to the point where
she committed suicide and it's horrible
like kids do these terrible things to
others to themselves like cutting and
look I admit I cut myself a few times in
high school but I had such a low
tolerance for pain that it went like and
you know because I couldn't really do it
I would start crying and what I really
tried to do it would hurt so bad that I
just I think that girl is just as
insecure depressed lonely and
misunderstood as my sister and I don't
know how you should deal with your
specific situation I just hope that you
know that it's fucking cruel as people
are we do a lot of terrible things to
escape paying and if you are a bully I'm
gonna find you and you on Monday stay
awesome Gotham